(foot steps)
(car engine starts)
(car honing)
- [Interviewer] All right, Repeat,
- [Repeat] Yes.
- [Interviewer] Repeat, why
did the call you repeat?
- Well, my name is Pete, but
it's repeat because I'm fair.
And down here, that's
really a particular trait,
it's really a good trait,
but you don't get it.
Everybody's trying to
win, even if it's a nego
they're trying to get over me,
I'm gonna give you what'd you pay for.
I might give you more
than what you pay for
but I'm never going to give you less
and it's always going to be quantity.
So once you deal with me,
you're gonna wanna repeat the process.
That's why they call me Repeat.
- [Interviewer] Where did you grow up?
Where do you come from?
- I grew up South Central
Los scandalous right here.
I grew up when I was born, it
was an area called Bob town,
it was where the school Bethune
is, Bethune Junior High,
but it was an apartment complex.
What they did was eminent domain
took the apartment complex, made us move
and built the rest of the school,
Just to be resolved Boys' school.
Those 69th and main street.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood?
Do you grew up with both your parents?
- My father died 1967, My
brother was a month old,
my youngest brother was a month old
and I was four years old.
My father died of a heroin overdose
and then the guys, instead
of taking to the hospital
at that time, he just
dumped him in the alley.
So after that I grew up, when I was 13,
I gravitated away from gang membership
you know I never wanted
it, but I scuba diving in.
I ran into an individual,
who took me out of his
boat while he was diving,
I thought it was the most
incredible thing in the world
especially I used to watch see him.
So when we finished,
I asked him do you think
I might be ready dive?
He said," sure if you're not scared,'
that's what I was planning on.
So the next day he went
and rented me a wet suit,
he had enough gear for two people.
So I put the gear on, I dove,
he asked me, what did I think?
I said it was the best thing
that ever happened in my life,
I wanna do it again.
So the next weekend he
brought me a wet suit,
every weekend I started a fish business.
I would sell fish for a
dollar, a quarter pound,
I'd bring up about 600 pounds of fish.
So I'd have like eight, $900,
but I'm only 14 years old at this time.
when I turned 16 I bought
four cars and motorcycle
and I moved into a double
wide mobile home for $38,000.
That's the much capital I saved,
well, I got in trouble because,
even though I had the money
I'm kind of like a car thief,
and just to me, it's the exciting
thing is adrenaline flow.
I got a call still in the car,
I went before the judge,
my attorney, asked me,
what are you gonna be
doing for the summer?
I said, well, I'm getting a summer job,
he said, that's not
enough, I know this judge,
you gotta give me something.
I said, well, I was
gonna go into the Navy,
I had been talking to a recruiter,
I never intended on going in,
I just talking to him.
And he said, well, I'll
see you back in court.
So we've gotten caught,
and he said, your honor, I
want to address the court.
He said, my client here had plans on going
to the United States Navy,
but at this fairly persistent, he's failed
he's convicted,
he want me to go in the
neighbor any other forces.
The Judge said," did you verify that?'
He said, yes, I talked to a
petty officer, first class hall.
And I looked at him,
we just went overboard.
He said, okay, It was
released me as Mr. Peter
and dropped the spelling,
when would be the soon as he could leave?
He said, tomorrow.
The judge said, well, you got a choice,
you can fight this case into three here,
or into three there, what did you choose?
I said, all right sir,
next day I was in the United States Navy.
I went in as the mechanics
made underwater welder.
They let me in at 16, three
months before I turned 17
they gave me a waiver because
I had a particular skill.
I was already a diver and they
had to teach me that aspect
so I went into the Navy, the
Navy wasn't exciting for me.
I got in trouble a few
times like everybody else
but I never started
drinking, that's why today,
I do not drink at all.
Com through the Navy,
well I had my daughter
when I was in the Navy.
But after the Navy, about two
three months on the street,
I didn't like it.
So I went into the army
throughout her lifetime
82 second airborne ,parachute specialist
everything that concerns the parachute.
In 1983, October 24th, the
Cuban invaded island in Granada.
You seen a movie with Chines Word called
"Heartbreak, Rage' or whatever,
had the Marines go to
the island at the end,
it wasn't the Marines,
It was 82nd airborne.
The army did that, Maneuver.
The Marines were nowhere around.
Anyway, I lasted five days on the Island,
I got hit with a two
millimeter board around
it blew up in front of me,
and it shredded my face.
It took my helmet off and
knocked my finger off,
I couldn't find it for a while,
It was only attached by the skin
and it spit my Palm over it.
I got shot twice to my frack jacket,
we didn't have dragons like they have,
now the Bulletproof jackets,
we had fragmentation proof jackets.
So one round hit me in the
stomach and came out on my back.
That's gonna hit me in the
ribs, through the scene,
and it broke two of my
ribs and I could reach in
I could feel it, but I
was trying to put it out
but it was too sticky to embed it.
So through that night I was gaining...
well first I woke up because
the ground was vibrating
the one Oh five houses was 11 miles away
but they still have enough
force to shake the ground.
The ground kept shaking,
so I opened my eyes
and I looked, I had blood in my eyes,
I was blast flashed
blinding and blast death.
I kept seeing these beads take off,
I remember where I placed the M60,
'cause I did the gun and placement.
I remember where I placed it
and I watched these bees go.
And I reason out that's the M60,
so I crawled in the direction
of the beads was coming from.
Well, and I got close enough,
spec for Ramsey put me in.
And I told him, "Look tell my wife
that I didn't die like a punk.'
And I went through these things,
thinking I was about to face death.
Anyway, through that night I was...
I would gain consciousness,
I would lose consciousness.
And I woke up when they
put me out of the foxhole
I broke my right collarbone,
when they pulled me up by
my right arm, it revived me,
I remember waking up,
I remember being put in their helicopter
because the down blast was in my face.
I remember, a lady saying,
"Make sure everybody's
secure, we're about to land.'
And I remember somebody
saying, "Do you feel this?'
I woke up in heaven,
I thought it was because I was
in the surgical lightening.
I tried to...
I knew I had patches on my
face, I tried to sit up.
It felt like somebody took
a stick about 12 inches long
and stuck inside my stomach,
'Cause I couldn't be in
my muscles was tight.
I tried to lift my hands and I
was wearing a Houdini jacket,
It made me panic, I started
shaking in the jacket.
I called a nurse, she ran in there.
I said, "Bitch, if you don't
take this shit over me,
I'm gonna kill you.'
She said," I'm not taking nothing off you,
and you gonna kill no body.'
She said," You came here in violence,
and you still violent,
so we're gonna leave it
on until you calm down.'
I broke down and start crying,
"Please take it, please take it off.
She's said, "okay, Stop crying,
I'm gonna call a doctor,
and If you say we take it off,
we'll take it off.'
A couple minutes later
the doctor comes in with two orderlies.
"Hey, are you going to be calm?
"when you came in, but
I'll tell you what happened
"But we're gonna take it off.
"If you act up, we're gonna hold you down
"and we go put you back
in the straight jacket.
And I said Pleas I'll be
calm I wont do anything.
So they took the straight jacket off.
He said, "You said you attacked the corny,
when you were landing in Florida.
I remember not attacking them,
but I remember the lady saying,
"make sure everybody's secure.
He said came to pull your harness tight
and you woke up, to put him in the field
for Nelson and you were
about to take them out.
We had to shoot you up,
He said, "And you woke up
on the surgical table.'
The doctor had his hand inside of you,
and he was so amazed, when you woke up,
he asked me, "How did you feel this?'
And he said, "Mother fucker,
did you feel this in you?'
He grabbed him around the
neck and started choking him.
So we knocked you out again,
He said, that's why we woke you up,
when you put a straight jacket on you,
'Cause you invited an individual.
I said, well, when I went out lastly,
I remember we at war, we were fighting,
so I guess they're telling about revive,
I was back in his own.
Anyway, what happened,
He said the suddenly you
had a good job on your face.
He said...
well I remember holding my face up,
every time I let go, it was dripped down.
I was like, Oh, I'm fucked
up, man I'm fucked up.
But he said,
"The surgeon did a very
particular job in macro surgery
in a couple of years people
won't even notice the scars,
you have to show him where the scars are.
When I look in the mirror,
I still see gigantic scar
that's why I've spent a lot of
time in front of the mirror.
But he was right when most people say,
"Oh I didn't really know he has scars,
he just said, he has long scar,
he said, you don't see this scar here,
this one here broke up my head on my head,
and my head got blew up and
chipped a piece of my skull.
You'll see these scars,
There's no, there's not really no,
so that's why I wear a beard.
I keep a beard, so I don't
want to see the scar myself.
I said, my finger came off,
my finger was back here
because they had my hand up
and I was feeling for my finger
and I found it it's hanging.
I took it, I put it in my
hand, I brought my fist up.
I took my first aid kit of my ass back
and I wrapped my hand up,
he said it was a good thing, You did that,
We were able to reattach the fingers.
He said, the tending is severed,
we won't be able to reattach that
but you'll get some feeling back
and you'll have some type of motion.
And this is the motion I had,
which makes it a good fucky finger.
well he said, were leaving
your right Palm open up
because we want it to
heal from the inside out,
we don't wanna close it up
and then it doesn't heal inside.
He said," Your back is
the same difference.'
He said, " We found it
around between your skin
and the jacket, the one in your ribs,
it broke two ribs only
thing we do is tape them up.
We want you to have a bowel movement
and do different things
that's what was the
blood in the stool.
Anyway, I'm revived, I got through that
or do I have no post-traumatic
stress syndrome at that time.
Six months later, I left the army
and I started selling drugs
because it was the thing to do
1985 freeway, rick and the rest of it.
I mean, we called it balling.
When you sell drugs, got that Rose racer
that Mercedes and they had all the toys
and the women gold,
jury cause row is worth
a lot in heavy gold chains.
it was like a sign of
rising, sign of bargain.
So what I used to do was,
I used to Jack ballers,
they talk too much and they
would get you talking about
Hey man, I know you live here on like 75,
No, I'm on 65th.
Oh 65th by kym
No, I'm about to crack blue house.
And they would give me all
the information I wanted,
I would follow them for five or six days.
And then when the time was right,
I go in, but I never took anybody with me
at the time I went in,
I was prepared to kill
everybody in the house.
Mama, daddy, dog, cat,
goldfish, anything that move,
Once I started shooting,
I was gonna hit everything
but me, I never had to do that,
because I became what
they called a creeper.
I been there and you never see me
and everything gone.
That's how people knew it was me.
They said, "we didn't see nobody.
"We didn't hear that.
"It had to be him.
But I would have my brother,
my brother was on top of the world.
I would have him, I
would give him the money
and he would show up in front of everybody
and hand me a lot of money.
"And so, where does he got his money from?
"He got it from his brother.
No it was Dave's money
I just made it look as
though my brother gave to me
and I would give him like 14, 15,000,
I mean I was getting $286, 64,004 bug
or bug we're making a
hundred thousand dollars
when I went in, I went in by myself
and again I went in one house
and it was nine dudes in there.
I came through the attic,
I pulled the vents off.
I walked on the Joyce, I
found interest into the house
because it's always a crawl space,
there's always attic
entrance, I pulled it up.
I entered the house,
quiet I had 57 Magnum.
I drew down and everybody,
everybody was sleeping.
I took a Duke blue diamond razor blade
and I cut everybody
pockets of front and back
and I cheeks to the wind,
I took everything they had.
I could cockpit all the drugs he had
and I took every piece of
weapon was in the house.
That's how they knew it was me,
because they didn't hear anything
and they know at this time
,I was the only one only
went in bold enough to come in the house
with nine different killers
and take these shit.
So anyway, I made a decision,
my wife at this time asked me to go
to the store and get some milk
for the cereal for my son.
Now this is my best decision,
I said, I'm going to wrap
supermarket four blocks away.
I'm going to need 30 to nine grand bags
of cocaine to go for a block.
I'm going to need a three 57 Magnum
a third-year Smith and
Weston a 25 automatic
assault on shotgun and
an automatic 22 rifle,
Oh, and in 1800 bullets.
I put 1800 rounds in my tool bag,
and I went to the store to get some milk,
I told her I'll be right back.
What had happened was,
at this time we used to pay
people to use their cars
like a $50 rock, a hundred dollar rock.
Well, I gave you do the $50 rock,
That's I supposed to have his
car for two or three days.
When he went home, his wife
couldn't appreciate it,
so she called the police
and reported the car stolen,
here I am going around the supermarket,
I walk out the house the
car has a ticket on it,
I don't really trip, I take
the ticket out off the window
in the glove box, the
police down the street,
I never seen him.
I start the car up and I pull off,
I got to the corner, the
police pulled up behind me
and it hit the lights and
he got onto the microphone.
It got off the car drew down on me,
"you in the car throw
the keys out the window
we want to see your hand.'
Oh, shit, that's the last day,
I said, man, you ain't gonna
see my ass with lumb the one.
But the light was red and
there was cars in front of me.
So they say, get out of
the car now, get out,
we want to see your hand.
And I was paying attention to them,
I didn't know the light had changed
until I seen that diesel fumes smoke
on my bus and I looked, the bus was gone,
I looked up light was green.
So I pressed it, I had
them about two blocks
I could've got away, I
had them about two blocks
but it was a Dodge dart, six cylinder
and it wasn't tuned up, It was backfired.
So I made a left turn on over my...
And I threw bag out of window,
I'm trying to get rid of the evidence
I got to me a lot and made a right turn
I threw another bag out the window,
went down a block, I'm doing like a cheer,
When I threw his bag it
hit the top of the window
and broke open and there was
like a snow storm in the car
blew back in my eyes I couldn't see,
I didn't have any time accident
but I made it to a jump off point.
I know my neighborhood, I know
where I'm going to jump out
of his car we call it
a bob billy out the car
and take off.
So when I got to 41st drive
the police blocked off
or I'm coming from mover,
I slammed the car in park,
open the door and I rolled out of the car.
40, 50 miles an hour, however it stopping,
whenever speed is stopping
at 25 miles an hour.
I rolled out to the car,
I drew a PLF parachute landing fall.
Guess what taught me that?
Anyway, I jumped up and I started it,
I looked back the car,
jumped out of the park
and went in reverse and
went back at the police car.
This guy actually
testified that I ran back
to the corner and pretty
reverse, never happened.
The car jumped gears and went back
I hear the the smash.
I hit a traffic accident
or run through the shortcut
but it's not a shortcut anymore.
It's built shelter, got cast
into water at a top gate closed
not looking like I'm gonna get
caught up going through that.
So I said, I got to get rid of this shit.
I take my tool bag with 1800 bullets
and my automatic 22 rifle,
I throw it over my head
and it sailed up and it
sailed on the roof, good.
I Reaching this out I
got the three 57 Magnum
and I throw it this way,
don't ask me for Western.
I threw it that way, putting
my automatic I threw it.
I come out with the soft
12th grade, do like this,
And it was slide out right into my hand.
When I got it out, he turned the corner
and I looked at him and he looked at me.
He said, "You black son of a bitch.'
And he had to skin, I told
him, don't do it, man.
And he stopped and we
had the staring contest.
He's standing and shaking,
I said, this motherfucker
very tried even to try it.
And you gonna behold, he tried to skin it.
When he tried to skin it, I had him here
but I dropped it here
and blew his legs money.
He got here maybe seven to
eight pellets, birdshot.
But it was enough because
they're five jumped
out and he seen his whole
life flash before him.
He dropped his service
reviver and he had to go out.
And I looked at the gun,
I said," why didn't you do that?'
But I said , gun (laughing)
Because I know I had no
intention to shoot him.
Anyway, I took him by the
barrel and I slung him.
I'm not going out that way,
I just shot a police officer,
they heard the bang here they come,
so I go over the gate and
I cut myself up on a wire
I roger the front and the
helicopter drops in on me.
But I run counter-clockwise
is the way it's going
when I get to the front,
I ran to the apartment next
door and I closed the gate.
I run upstairs and I'm
looking for an exit,
I'm looking for a way out,
and I just stayed there
nowhere to go, I come back to the front
I sit and watched the
helicopter, I watched the police
they do a house to house, to house search
but they never come into
the apartment building.
Three hours later, they're
leaving, they didn't find me.
So they're egging me or they'll search
and research and do detectives
and they'll come up, we'll be that way,
but they didn't find me in that search.
So they left, I said, "I'm
gonna give it about 15 minutes
and I'm out of here.'
This lady comes out to
the house, I knew her.
She come out of the house.
"Oh, how are you doing?'
I said, "I'm okay, Minnie, how are you?'
"I'm okay,'
She said, well, "Take care of yourself.'
I say, "You to Minnie,'
She closed the door,
I knew this lady, man.
I helped her carry her groceries in.
Anyway, she goes back in the
house and calling the police.
I didn't know this, the
police pulled up in front.
It's all vacant, I'm leaved
they pulled up in front and
it gets out and he's talking
to me radio and he points
out department field.
And I stand up and my heart
and my ass dropped to my feet.
I know they're coming
in, so I run to the back.
I run downstairs, we gonna
do it the open field track
and field obstacle course.
I go over the door and it has no door nob.
I try to stick my finger
in and turn the latch,
I can't do it, and there's
nothing to turn it with.
I hear them beating the window (mimic)
mom, mom, come over the window,
would you open the door,
would you open the door.
And I went to the front(mimic)
Son, son, could you come over the door?
And it makes me do comes out
and you look down the hallway.
I said, get your motherfucker
ass in the ground.
He turns ready, closes his door.
(mimic) mom, mom...
So at your front door,
the son is behind him
because I see the shadow.
They got one of their German shepherds
and his dog isn't barking he's whirling.
He's ready to go.
(mimic)
Get the fuck out of here.
I take my shirt off,
I stuff to the mailbox
they'd been doing
plaster work on the wall.
So we drown, I grab a plastic bag,
I throw my shirt, I go to the door,
I open it and I'll walk
out they grabbed me
and they throw me out of the
way, and they all run in.
And I'm walking down the street,
but they got a perimeter,
I'm making halfway through the parameter
and they went back out, stopped him.
Go on your knees and
all this kind of stuff,
they takes me back to the car
and said, we're going to
do an open field lineup
I know who told me because it's
the only person who seen me.
So I inconspicuously I
look up at her window
and I see the curtain open,
"Yeah, that's him, we got him.'
(indistinct)
For seven years, I thought of 1,003 ways,
I was gonna kill Mimie.
I was going to throw a snake in her house.
(laughing)
That's right before I go to bed isolate
and figure it out how I will kill Mimie
(laughs)
That's how I do stress because...
I came up with some pretty exciting way
'cause I was going to get her,
but she died and I was like her than me.
There are 33 prisons in California.
I've been in 24, from Cabaukan
bay down to Chukawalla.
And Pelican Bay is the
worst place I've ever been.
I was so miserable, I had
migraines, I couldn't sleep.
I go to the psychiatrist,
the plates was...
I'm dreaming the place he had teeth,
the dish washing was
trying to kill me man.
He was stressed me out,
It took me three years
to get out of there.
I took him to court,
I sued in for a change of location.
When the court ordered
them to send me South
they sent me to the next
yard or 300 yards South
like it was a joke.
I told her, I contacted the court
and told them that, they
turn this into a joke.
The judge ordered him,
He said, "You either send this man South",
I'm gonna have you explain
why he's not going.
That's an order.
Send me to Chukawalla
Every prison I've been
here, I had to fight
first had to fight with a black,
because I don't particularly
talk the same way, man.
I mean, I was in a stayed there 11 months
and I never said anything
to myself before 11 months,
he couldn't believe I
never said a word to him
on the yard for 17 months to Tracy,
I never said anything to
anybody or I do the jake head.
He can't talk, he don't say anything.
No. I just decided not to speak to them.
They won't talking about
anything I wanted to hear.
Country, Country was the largest
dude on a yard, 600 pounds.
I mean, this dude lived so much weight,
you can't get them all over the bar.
The bar has been like a
U and he's lifting them.
This dude had three years,
he caught 39 more years
but 18 rapes, he raped me,
he was called a booty bandit rape you.
One particular day Country
turned his eyes on me
I'm coming off the yard and
you got to get searched to come
over a yard and come say,
"Hey man, I'm gonna fuck
you to you tonight.'
I said, what?
He said, "You're going be my bitch,
"I'm gonna wear your ass
out I been watching you
you got a nice ass.
And I said, "okay, turned around came up
and try to Pat me down.
I went to my cell in eight
wing, my cell was 214.
The doors are nomadic, so I
called the garden open two 214.
He looked and see its you push the button,
the door open.
I went in, put my gloves on,
put my long sleeve shirts on
got my best boots, tied
them up real tight,
jeans belt (indistict)
and stood by the door.
So I'm standing by the door
with an apathetic expression.
Country walks by him
and he's talking to somebody,
he's engaged in conversation.
Hey, excuse me, "what'd you want man?'
I said, remember, "You're
supposed to be fucking me, man.'
"Oh yeah, y'all come over there.
And everybody heard this,
everybody got quiet.
You guys can't do anything
until it happened.
So we go to the third year, open 339.
We walk off in his cell,
and Country tears his
shirt off like Hong Kong.
Like the restaurant is
that Teddy shirt off.
He showed me all these muscles,
and he said, "Bring your
ass here motherfucker.
So I generally step off of the cell
"Close 339,'
The cell door come across in the closing
and lock Country swung at or went a under
And I jumped at him, I
caught him on a pixel
and I bit the largest piece of chicken,
I ever bitten in my...
I bit a chunk out this dude so big,
blood squirted out everything.
But it was all in my mouth
because I severed it.
He started screaming and I spit it out
"Ahh!, motherfucker I'm gonna kill you.'
You swung at me again,
I jumped on his back
and I bit on the other side,
I've been to, I mean, I didn't know.
My jaws were open that far.
I bit a nice gigantic chunk out of him,
and I split it on the floor.
Now he knows he's locked
in a cell with a cannibal.
He came to fuck, I made him...
He says," I mean, this
motherfucker did it well.
(laughs)
I mean, it's a skeleton over here.
So he swung at me again and I
tried to bite his nipple off
but I got a bit it and
I ate a lot of pixels.
I bit a large silk large so blood...
Country running himself.
(laughing)
He's running to get away from me
and I'm chasing it dude this is this up.
(mimic)
Blood coming out (indistinct),
We fight for about 30 minutes
and I'm tired, he tired.
Like I'm a hands on lady,
and I'm saying, "I feel like eating this,
and he's standing up'
and I know he's finish swing at me
'Cause he's doing like this.
You don't know which body
on bits to hold on to.
He's bleeding like a slaughter
pig and then bits hurt.
Country is still screaming and crying.
"I'm gonna kill you, I'm gonna kill you.'
And would say "I'm gonna
kill this motherfucker.'
So punching him in the balls,
I get them to real good, clear
and he reaches his hand, ooh,
He bend over, I reached
my hand, pass his hand
I grabbed his dick, I pulled it out
and I tried to bite that motherfucker off.
I said," That's how my practice get off.
I'm gonna say he'll
never raped nobody else.
And I'm trying to get there...
Remember Country try motherfuckin awhile.
He grabbed my hand and he holding me back,
I'm trying to get it, I
just want at least nip it.
(laughs)
A razor cut anything,
Let this motherfucker know I bit him,
"Pleas don't no, no no no pleas.'
And he throws me back, I
had to wonder to come back.
He reached under the TV,
he came out with a cone nice sword
I didn't know they had
knife that long in prison.
He came with (indistinct)
get out of my cell
I said, "I'm out of here men, Oh men 330.'
They open the door, everybody thought
I was in there getting killed.
They feel sorry for him,
for all the screaming.
He just knew, he was just
fucking the shit out of me.
I stepped out of that
cell, I have a Mark on me
Country had a broken nose,
three gigantic holes.
He didn't know how he was gotten on me
like two black eyes because,
when I was booked I had
to smoke for some reason.
And every time country came
around me, it'll get quiet.
When he walked in the room where I was at,
it would get quiet.
So I know he was there
and I was standing up
and I turned looking at
him, he'd looked at me.
makes his mean expression and it turns
and he'll walk out the door.
For three months this is
when we play cat and mouse
'cause I'm gonna eat this motherfucker up
he already know what I'm ready to do
So he came up to me,
He said, "Look man, let me talk to you.'
He said, "I'm sorry about that man,
"you ain't gonna about
me to worry about me
"I was wrong you right, man
you got me feel better man.
"You got to worry about it no more.
I said, all right, country laugh,
every time I seen him, I still stood up
and watched his ass.
I wasn't going give him a break,
but that's how I got the
booty band in that 87 cells.
(laughing)
Okay, here, and 16...
No, 2016, they started a program
called MRCP Men's Retreat
Community Program,
It's like a halfway house.
So there are 17,000
individuals who qualify
by location in Los Angeles.
There are 10,000 that qualify,
because they meet criteria.
There are 3000 that were interviewed,
but are only 400 that made it
because somebody said, let's try this guy.
This guy is intelligent,
he got seven different college degrees,
he got 17 certified vocational
skills which is what I had.
I mean, he writes
screenplays and manuscripts.
He stays busy, he types
every words a minute,
all this is all oral I
got, I got try myself,
I speak four languages,
I taught myself Spanish
by reading the Spanish Bible
from Genesis to revelation.
(speaks in foreign language)
I speak four languages, I
taught myself, nobody taught me.
It just like I said, I retain
90 to 95% of anything I read.
I read 4,178 books in 31 years,
I know because I counted.
What'd he took place in was,
they made the decision to see me
they interviewed me and
asked me, did I want to go?
Yea wanna go to the street.
So it's about a week later,
I was in a van, handcuffed in a van.
We went in the alley, across
the street from MacArthur park.
They took the handcuffs
off and jus say you can run
but if you run, we gonna give you life.
We're going to strike you out.
If you got strikes me, I got 52 strikes
I had 52 altered rounds,
each round was account.
So I got 52 strikes, I don't have 52.
So anyway, I went into MCRP program
I fought about eight marks
and I completed the program.
My time was up, my parole came
and they keep me up at the front door.
My mom died like about three months
before I got on over there.
My mom was the last day,
she was my last anchor.
She really kept me in place
and she tried to wait.
She said, she'd be there
when I came home, she tried,
she didn't make it.
My mom had Parkinson's and
Parkinson's is kind of...
This is a dysfunctional disease
because it attacks the nervous system
and the person is trying to move.
But all they're doing
is shaking and it starts
with the smaller muscles,
facial muscles of the neck.
I mean, I learned so much
about parking is when
my mom started going through
it because I would talk
to her in the fall and
she would ask me questions
and I had to answer because I
remember a lot of what I read.
That's how I got, that's
how I got down here.
When my Mom died I started
careering, I started caring
I just...
People don't come here to live
People come here to die and they too say,
who gonna come here to live,
I work, but I would give
him to come here to die,
scrape everybody doing.
So that's what happened once I got here.
- [interviewer] (indistinct) three years?
- Three years, I got out
in her 16, October 17th
16 past I started street.
- [Interviewer] Where are you staying now?
- I stayed on the street
I center tip for...
I mean I just started staying
here for the past four months.
You know, that's been means.
I used to just sleep on the sidewalk.
It was a man, I saw you going
to the sidewalk right out,
man coulda got you assist only
chance if you got to get me,
you better get me while I'm sleeping
because you can't do anything when I want,
I watched, the Avengers
and captain America
told doc Peter up, he said,
now it'd be a good time for
you to get angry Doctor.
Doctor peter said, "That's
my secret, I'm always angry.'
That's me, I'm always
angry, I came out angry.
Even if I smiled, I stay angry,
but I directed it towards people....
I mean, I'm not God, I
don't have a good sense.
I had a good sense of judgment.
People would have fuck
with me, people that...
and I changed the way they look.
I've had 32 fights down
here, and there's 32 people
who look different now
they have lacerations,
abusing, subdural hematomas
that won't ever go away
because I changed the way they look.
I tell them if you
can't fight for an hour,
don't fuck with me.
I don't even let you win
the first 10 or 15 minutes,
but I'm gonna have 45 minutes beating
your motherfucker ass systematically.
And I'm going to do it, I'm
going to spend a whole hour.
Just remember, just taking a year apart
(indistinct)
Doc hit me in the chest with a shovel,
I took a shovel from him,
I choked him out until he passed out.
I let him go, I sat on his chest.
I slapped him till he woke up.
I said, now here is the
ass kicking I promise you.
And for about 30 minutes,
just all face shots
just fetal for my hands broke
but even when I was broke
I was feeling with the us mainland.
I never go started, I
don't go looking for it.
They have to say something to me
because I don't do a lot of talking.
I am associate, I'm not antisocial.
I don't care who you socialize with.
I'm a social, your friends,
my friends, I don't socialize.
My brothers died here, my younger brother.
And you kinda, want them he was saying,
living on if you don't say nothing to him
he don't like you either
like you or you don't.
There's no gray hair, but I
ain't never did nothing to her.
I don't know something about you,
maybe you don't like
the way he cut your hair
but either I like them or
I don't if I like him I talked to them.
My smiles don't come easy because
I don't have nothing to smile about.
Not really, when people
say, where are you alive?
Only because I haven't no deliberately,
but I have studied
99.7% effective is jumping
in front of a Metro rail.
Each wheel is against you life.
97% effective as a
shotgun to the mountain.
92% effective as jumper
of ability in our cat for
that will allow you to
exceed 80 miles an hour,
86% effective is hanging yourself
'Cause you gotta get rid of, everybody
and send them on vacation
and get away from them.
That's what Robin Williams
did because he studied
people want to die, they
know how they going to do it
and you can't stop them.
People who tell you to go
die and make a phone call.
They want attention.
The ones who are going do
it, they don't talk about it.
They don't tell nobody
that's why such a shock.
I've studied it, I stood an I look at it
And I'll wait, I'll wait.
I mean, something good might happen
something good might happen.
but I'm like, he will commute.
You don't give a fuck, you got in heads
and I don't give a fuck,
I don't go look for him.
I don't know what I they're like fuck it
Dark wing, duck are underdogs
in for canine over you.
I don't know what I did,
when your daughter come out the club
and she drunk I make
sure she get in the car.
I don't touch her, I make
sure she get in the car
and she can sleep there
and nobody gonna mess with her
I'm gonna stay right
there ,like a watch dog.
I don't want to make sure your
son, when he comes down here
I told him, man, you
shouldn't go down there.
But if he has to come down
here to purchase drugs
I tell him I'm gonna get you
in and I'm gonna get you out.
Only thing you gonna do
is you gonna do exactly
what I tell you, what I tell you to do.
And don't say nothing to nobody.
And I can assure you, you'll
live through this experience.
I do that I grew up there
walk women to their car
and not to get at them
because I only love one.
And she don't love me, she's
doing something different
but I make sure they get there
because somebody wanted them home safe.
If they've been drinking, I
try and talk to them today.
So grew up because I don't
drink, Imagine me drunk.
It'd be a whole bunch of
black eyes around here.
(laughing)
Because, drunk mind
does with a sober mind,
wants to do, and I've been pushing
(laughing)
A lot of girls, with black
guys to present(indistinct)
Anyway, that's what I do at night time
I go in I help people,
somebody's got to, if I kid out of field
I love the underdog and I
go in, I try to help them
if they don't want it
don't I try to like them
hang around and make sure they get away
because I'm going to intervene,
I'm going to intervene because I mean,
I give a fuck about you.
I just, you can't do nothing with me.
I mean, I don't give a fuck
If you kill me, you be doing me a favor.
So that's how I got here,
that's what I'm doing here.
Am I going to stay here?
I can eat anytime on
want to anytime any day.
And I got idea, hundreds
of million dollar ideales.
I do have a lot of time to think about it
And here I've worked at
Jasmine's. I can't do.
I just can't type anymore
because my left hand
doesn't work anymore,
but I don't tell nobody.
I don't put it out here
because that's a disadvantage.
Somebody to take advantage of that.
Autumn Muffet can't lose
that, man no, I can't.
I can't open my butt to regulate
the one that's gonna get
you, that's what I am.
- [interviewer] Thank you so
much for sharing your story.
(laughing)
- You welcome man so that's
(indistinct)
(laughing)